nos preguntan que el lado es
perpendicular al lado de aquí tenemos el
lado cede y aquí está indicado que este
ángulo es de 90 grados eso es lo que
quiere decir este ángulo recto chiquito
sale entonces el lado que es
perpendicular al lado cede es el lado d
vamos a ver si está en las opciones si
lado d
muy bien vamos a hacer otros cuantos
problemas a ver éste dice selecciona la
categoría correcta de cada figura ok
es para algunos lados paralelo sin
ninguno perpendicular ve es para algunos
lados perpendiculares y ninguno paralelo
y se es para los que tienen lados
paralelos y perpendiculares ok este
ejercicio está interesante vayamos con
la primera figura ésta tiene todos estos
ángulos de 90 grados que nos indica que
este lado por ejemplo es perpendicular
este de acá entonces por lo menos tiene
lados perpendiculares pero también tiene
lados paralelos porque como este lado y
este lado
ambos son perpendiculares al de acá
entonces son paralelos la respuesta
sería c tiene lados paralelos y
perpendiculares en este de acá tenemos
ángulos perpendiculares a ángulos rectos
más bien entonces tenemos segmentos
perpendiculares y no tenemos segmentos
paralelos
parece ser que ningún par de segmentos
tiene la misma dirección entonces la
respuesta sería ve algunos lados
perpendiculares y ninguno paralelo en
este de acá tenemos que este es paralelo
a este así está indicado y que éste es
perpendicular a este entonces la
respuesta es c aquí tenemos un
paralelogramo verdad nos indican que
éste es paralelo a este y este es
paralelo a este pero no hay ángulos
rectos no están indicados entonces la
respuesta sería a sólo tiene este lados
paralelos en esta figura de acá pues
tenemos un triángulo que está indicado
que este segmento mide lo mismo que éste
que ahorita no nos importa pero lo que
sí nos importa es que está indicado que
este ángulo de acá es de 90 grados y por
supuesto aquí no hay lados paralelos
porque es imposible que en un triángulo
haya dos lados para
de los entonces la respuesta sería b y
finalmente en esta figura
notemos que todos los lados o bueno cada
pareja de lados opuesta opuestos son
paralelos entonces la respuesta sería ah
y no hay ningún lado en ningún lado
perpendicular a otro entonces por eso
sólo tenemos lados paralelos y ninguno
perpendicular vamos a verificar la
respuesta muy bien